Fans of the famous Dude Perfect group will
surely be familiar with the two twins, Coby
and Cory Cotton, also known as Twin #1 and Twin
#2, respectively. It's hard to keep up with them;
although they are identical twins,
the two of them lead different lives.
While both brothers are a part of the crazy
trick shot crew, one of them is a published
author with a wife and kids. The other has
lost the most battles in Dude Perfect history.
Younger brother Cory Cotton can lay
claim to having the most wins, but
there's a lot you probably don't know about him.
One of the first things you will notice
about Cory when you start to dig deeper into
his life is his real first name
is not Cory. Born July 17, 1987,
Cory Cotton was born William Cory Cotton,
according to the Dude Perfect Fandom site.
This is also the case for his twin brother,
Coby, who was born John Coby Cotton.
Of course, it doesn't exactly help keep things
simple when two twins with similar names like Cory
and Coby become friends with a guy named Cody, as
in Cody Jones. Fortunately it's easy for fans to
tell the three men apart, as the twins are easily
distinguishable based on physical characteristics
and Cody looks nothing like them at all.
Speaking of twins, they tend to run in the Cotton
family. Cory Cotton is already known as Twin #2,
born only a minute behind his twin
brother, Coby, who's known as Twin #1.
This twin-sibling rivalry is one of the
best dynamics seen throughout the various
Dude Perfect media, and Cory seems
to better his brother in that aspect.
Cory has won a total of seven battles,
while his older brother has only won four.
And it doesn't look like the twin-sibling
rivalry will stop with Cory and Coby.
On November 18, 2018, Cory and his wife,
Amy Surplus, became parents to twins and
named them Crew and Collins. They're
probably too young for a fierce sibling
rivalry like the one between their dad and
uncle, but it will likely happen one day.
Most of the guys in Dude Perfect have some sort
of role outside of making incredible trick shots.
According to Fandom, Cory likes to help the
editing team make the final version of the video.
This may not seem to be within his particular
wheelhouse — Cory received a Bachelor of Arts in
Speech Communications from Texas A&M University,
according to his LinkedIn profile — but when
an extra hand was needed for the editing
process, Cory was the first to jump in.
Coby, also a communications
major, helps with the mobile apps.
The Dude Perfect guys have had to face some
hilarious and sometimes cruel punishments over
the years; Unfortunately for Cory, he received
probably one of the worst punishments ever.
"Just, I have had a bad streak."
In Overtime 7, Cory had to shave his eyebrows.
Eyebrows don't grow back overnight; it takes
about 4-16 weeks for eyebrows to grow back.
This is hands-down the longest lasting punishment,
making it probably one of the
worst ones fans have ever seen.
Cory doesn't only make trick-shot videos
and suffer through entertaining punishments
for a living. In 2011, Cory published Go Big:
Make Your Shot Count in the Connected World.
This book took readers behind the
scenes of Dude Perfect and dove deep
into the "Go Big" philosophy. The
book also goes into their secrets
of success and shares some tips on how
to take your passion to the next level.
It's just one of the many things the
guys from Dude Perfect have accomplished,
aside from the YouTube series, documentary, mobile
apps, and tours. Most of the guys have admitted
they don't want to make trick-shot videos forever.
Although they would like to keep the brand alive,
they realize they will have to focus on other
things, such as family and other career ventures.
For Cory, he has his three children and wife to
focus on, and possibly more books in the future.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite YouTubers are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.